you ever wake up with a rat next to you
looking at you I grew up with rats I
ain't got much I grew up with rats you
ain't getting a good out of me on to the
next one what she does she doesn't know
he's coming in she's on to it a mother
knows she's on to it yeah she's on to it
she's odd to it
that's lovely that's lovely
god bless him it's not for me to tell
people what they can learn it's you know
it doesn't matter because I made a movie
that I'm sitting here telling people
what they should do that's not what it's
about it's what they are doing not what
I think they should do you know this is
love this is family so that's great
stuff good for you Charlie
[Applause]
the mortis men we need more this need
more of this this is what it's all about
they're bad news sells but good news is
forever that's good stuff what do I
think that it's more important what they
think then what I think you know I like
I said you know just reach out help
people man it's it's just good stuff so
give them a breathalyzer with what's he
doing shaping them god Bless You officer
Tony cause some good feeling each one
teach one each one reach one lift
somebody else up make them better help
him out
is he still working yeah the guy kept
the job he's the president of McDonald's
now and he did now he's that's his
children and make dad know I gave was
gonna gotta sleep real heroes
no soundtrack no score real life I don't
you know again what makes a real hero I
don't want to let anybody off the hook
we all have a responsibility to do the
right thing to do our job and as a man
who's protecting and defending his
country who came in you know to see his
loved ones and that's what we ought to
do it ought not be special that's you
know not supernatural that's natural
that's life that's what we should be
doing good fam look in the mirror yo
you'll find the answer ask yourself the
question you know what you should to be
responsible
[Music]